how did you mean Michael Jackson how did
I meet Michael Jackson so after all this
time of me learning his dance steps and
everything I had an opportunity to um to
go to an audition
and I met him on my 18th birthday
actually it wasn't at that time it was
the audition was for remember the time
on my 18th birthday was still in high
school so I landed the job and then we
had rehearsals and that's when I first
met Michael was doing rehearsals from
Remember The Time and um man we
rehearsed on the Backlot of Universal
Studios which is really cool
um and wait sorry we shot on the back
lot of Universal Studios we actually
rehearsed at a studio which is no longer
around called Alley Cat off of Gower and
sunset and we rehearse there for several
weeks shot it on the back lot of
Universal Studios and uh yeah it was you
know I I I I was really happy to be
there I never thought it'd be such an
iconic music video but I mean that music
video is amazing you know uh John
Singleton unfortunately passed away
recently
um the director who did boys in the hood
which was a which was a movie that I
love because it was the areas that I
grew up in and it's about boys who look
like me that grew up in those kind of
areas one guy you know did turn into the
kind of the dark side on the other side
you know the the other uh boy who were
and they were friends you know grew up a
different way and and then and I totally
got that the ironic the the ironic thing
is that John Singleton's birthday was
also January 6. so it was like on
January 6th on my birthday got this job
and John Singleton also January 6 was
was uh what's the director so that was
kind of cool
wow yeah and when you went there how did
how did Michael come out like when he
entered the room like what was the mood
in the room like so you know we're in
there rehearsing the dance steps now the
way we typically do this if you're
working with a large artist you
typically
um work with them separately so they
learned the dance steps they know them
before they come into the rehearsal the
idea behind that is that they want to
come in looking like they know what
they're doing as opposed to learning the
dance steps and seeing you you get to
see all their foibles and all their
mistakes and everything like that
so by the time he came in he already
knew the dance steps um at least a big
chunk of them so we were in rehearsal
and then you know the door opens and he
comes in and we all get quiet we're like
and we're trying to rehearse still
but you're still looking on the side of
your eye that's Michael Jackson like
okay
and then he comes out in the middle
and the choreographer Fatima Robinson
she introduces him we all clap for him
and he's like you know thank you thank
you for being here but very quiet and
then now it's just a thing now that
Michael's there we've been rehearsing
we're kind of just going through the
motions but now that Michael's here
everybody pulls up
everybody's like ready like all the
dance steps you hit him hardest as hard
as you can like it's now what in dance
in the Nets where we call that being
full full out dancing full out with full
energy full intensity everyone's killing
it like and so Michael's like okay like
I you could tell that he sees what this
could be he gets he gets into it then he
comes in he does his steps but yeah it's
like you know
nothing nothing beats the energy of when
he's in the room and when you are with a
bunch of group uh when you're with a
group of dancers who know what they're
doing and are really good at what they
do
it's you can feel the energy in that
room and that's how it was in every
rehearsal and then when we start
shooting that's how it was
um and we carried that same you know I
mean I got a chance to work with him
when I was 18 and when I was 19 and then
for a good five-year stint went around
the world toured the world with him and
everything uh for the history World Tour
so
um that energy
it whenever we were around each other uh
whenever I was with him and other
dancers uh that energy was was always
there so there was nothing like it
when you're waiting for him to enter he
enters you're 18 and you know this is
what I want to do with the rest of my
life or at least for some time of it
yeah did you feel like I'm closer to it
or did it feel even more intimidating
no I was never intimidated uh with him
because again I still had that mindset
that I don't care who you are
um we're all going to grow old we are
all going to get sick we're all going to
die so I've never intimidated by anyone
I was just more like wow I actually did
it you know after all these these years
from the age of 14 13 years of age
saying I was going to do it here five
years later I'm actually doing it so it
was more of you know more more Elation
more Glee
um a relief that actually after all this
time and and you know I have a lot of
friends who became lawyers and doctors
and other things because we were friends
in junior high we didn't go to the same
high school but I have friends now who
like are very successful in that World
um and I didn't go down that path
because I had I had a different mindset
and to see like okay here's the
justification of all the hard work
here's the validation of all the hard
work and it's kind of nice to have that
so for me once I once I had that moment
I was cool so at that point you know
it's game on and now it's just about you
know it's it's this healthy competition
that dancers have between each other we
don't say anything but we know we're
trying to outdo each other and it's in a
loving way it's not in a way like okay
I'm better than you it's more like okay
you do this okay now watch this and we
try to you know up each other and
Michael has the same kind of thing so
when he's performing he feeds off the
energy that we have as dancers going
back and forth and that pulls him up as
well so you know there's like I said the
energy in that room is just insane and
it's contagious and and I carried that
with me whenever uh I did other jobs
with Michael and now as a director
and so did you say I need to approach
him or no I'm going to take this slow
I'm going to let him see that I'm
dedicated to this I have discipline and
and when it's when I'm ready we'll go to
the next step yeah when it comes to
Michael you know you don't think about
approaching them no you you you're there
to do your job and so you want to
remember your job is first you know
um it's not like I never thought well
first of all I'm 18 so I'm not thinking
we're going to go out and get any drinks
or something like that I'm just like I'm
there to do a job
um I'm blessed to do this job I'm
blessed to be the youngest person in
this room doing this job so I'm just
happy to be there honestly at that point
by the time I got to be
um
in my 20s that's when for me I wanted to
like
um I wanted to have more of a closer
relationship because we had worked so
often by that point because in 90 so it
you know we did I remember the time
first then the very next year almost
around the same time on my birthday we
worked on the American Music Awards uh
for a song called Dangerous
um and then we did some we did a short
film called ghosts and then I toured the
world with him on the history World Tour
so I've been working with him on so many
different projects and so
um at that point is when I felt like I
could have a conversation with them at
least you know hey how's it going today
how was your day those kind of things
but in the very beginning no I didn't
say anything I'm like oh okay so because
I know some people have this mindset
it's but maybe it helped that you grew
up in La that they want to just like
make a beeline to a certain person and
write them a note or whatever it is and
try to jump the line so to speak and and
I don't know if that necessarily works
but I know people think that it might
yeah so no and you know the idea of
going towards him to you know to
communicate with him other than to say
hello I mean no I was there to do a job
so that's first and foremost and then
everything else would just happen on its
own organically you know you would hope
so it didn't when I was you know on
those first couple of jobs but then
later on things things started happening
where we can have more conversations
about things in life at that point I was
married I had you know a child so I can
have I had a lot more that I could talk
about you know
hey did you take I know this is a
strange question but did you take the
bus home that night after that that
rehearsal very good question regarding
the bus so I was still busing it
um through that point I think at that
point I um
no I probably brought my mother's car
but that job was what got me my very
first car which almost killed me
um
that job got me a I bought my very first
car which was like a 74 Volkswagen
Beetle and I was working the following
year for a group called in Vogue I used
to be a dancer for them we were going
getting ready to go on tour and doing
rehearsals I'm driving the bug in North
Hollywood off of Burbank Boulevard and
I'm driving I I Smell Smoke I turn
around whoosh this big Fireball comes
from the back of the of the car because
underneath the back seat it's stubble
and it it sits right on top of the
battery so somehow the stubble in the
back seat got caught on fire probably
from the battery or the engine or the
heater or something like that which is
in the back as well and so while we're
driving I'm like oh my gosh and my hair
is grades from being cinched and I jump
out of the car
in the you know in in the street on
Burbank Boulevard and I'm rolling in the
street I'd kick off my shirt I take it
off and I you know make sure I'm okay
the carviers hits a tree and catches
this tree on fire oh my God yeah that's
my first car but I got it
oh my goodness
wow
yeah
it was scary of all the people you've
danced with in your life all the
different names all the unknown dancers
that are probably amazing as well where
does Michael Jackson rank as far as
dance moves yeah as far as where he
ranks as far as dance moves it's really
interesting because I've got a chance to
work with Usher who copies Michael
Jackson I've watched Chris Brown who
copies Michael Jackson Jason Derulo
copies Michael Jackson so I would say
that Chris Brown is probably one of the
most talented dancers
but he doesn't hold a candle to Michael
because Michael's the originator you
never outdo the originator
um so for me as far as the dances are
concerned there's nobody like Michael
like there's very few people that that
I've seen dance that can make people cry
Michael can do that I have a friend of
mine who his name is Matthew rushing he
dances he actually is the artistic one
of the artistic directors at avenali uh
now
um he was the second person that I've
ever seen somebody dance and make people
cry in the audience like he is a
beautiful dancer
um and Michael was the first so unless
you can do that and move people with
that kind of emotion
yeah you don't hold a candle to Michael
and when you were 18 and and in that
crowd you know for I remember at the
time doing the dance moves was there
something in you that said you don't you
don't outdo the originator like did you
want to you know you're young and you
you're excited and you want to you know
show your your stuff did you have to
remind yourself that or that came later
no I think the idea of you know not
topping the originator I think
I'm really competitive so I don't care
who you are whether you're Michael
Jackson or somebody else I'm going to
try to outdo you uh there's been times
when that has actually got me into
trouble
like
um so no when I'm 18 I'm not even
thinking I like that but as I further
along and get better at my dances keep
in mind I'm still in high school so you
know I I hadn't gotten from from 10th
grade to 12th grade I was a completely
different dancer I could do so much more
I could do the splits I could turn I
could jump I could leap I could do
Russians I could do a lot of I mean
pretty much almost anything I want my
body to do I could probably do by the
time I was 18. so the confidence was
definitely there but
um as I started working after you know
between the Michael Jackson jobs I'm
doing other jobs for other artists as
well and you know you do more and more
work you gain more and more confidence
and so by the time we go out on tour
with Michael
um you know there's some nights when
you're when you have it when you're just
killing it like dance wise and this is
one night we were in Seoul South Korea
I'll never forget this so
um we're performing Smooth Criminal and
we're getting ready to do the famous
Lean Forward
um it's with criminal when you watch the
music videos and also when you watch the
live shows you see this moment where
Michael Jackson and the dancers lean
really far forward and then they come
back up
now we do this live on stage
and you know to to do the trick you need
to have really strong stubbing muscles
because it's all stubbing muscles you
literally tighten your body and then you
lean forward and your feet are locked in
to the floor
one night I went so far no no lie my
nose was probably this far from the
floor now this is from a standing
position so imagine going all the way
down down down down down down down down
to your this close from the floor and
I'm next to Michael but I'm behind
Michael so if Michael's here
I'm here and you can obviously see me
and I I was feeling it that night it was
just a good night I was just performing
so well and I went too far
and so the show's over
and Lavelle Smith who is one of my
mentors in dance uh he was also the
dance Captain for Michael he's been like
he's been Michael from the dangerous
World Tour he's been Michael like he was
in the original Smooth Criminal
he came up to me and said hey Michael um
Michael asks if you can make sure you
don't leave that for him next time
interesting I said yeah I'm sorry I'm
sorry
so you know there's going back to you
what you're saying yes there's been
times when I was so hyped up I know I
never thought I was going to be better
than the originator but there's been
times when like I was just you know
feeling it and I kind of went a little
bit too far
you mentioned that you're competitive
yeah and you said sometimes it's gotten
you in trouble aside from that which it
sounds like you corrected it how has it
gotten you in trouble
well
now with this you know this new role of
me being a writer and director
um typically the way I have I have two
managers and typically the way it works
when it comes to my work as a writer is
I'll write something and I'll give it to
them to look at it give me notes on and
then I'll receive it back and you know
make some corrections based upon the
notes there's been times when I I was
impatient and I wanted to get something
sold faster and so as a result I would
not send it to them I tend to write to
the person
um you know write to the executive at
you know a studio directly
um and and in those situations
you know you have what are called
General meetings general meeting being
that those set up my managers will set
up me to have a meeting with an
executive at Paramount Studios or at bet
or you know at Lionsgate and I'll meet
this person
we have a great Rapport literally it's a
dual IQ meeting do I like Courtney
meeting and you know the 30 minutes to
45 minutes and I come in there and they
you know tell them a little about about
my background where I come from by then
they would have seen um I have a short
film which was a A hip-hop Musical that
I did while I was still in college that
was like my my thesis project and that
project is the is what got me the
meeting
so by then we've had some discussion we
you know they've seen some of my work
um and then by the end I usually get
their contact information so I have
their phone number the email address and
they're like Hey whenever you have
anything you know coming up in the
future let me know
even though they say that the correct
route is to still go through your
managers and have your manager or your
agent send them the script
sometimes because of my um
competitiveness because of my
impatientness I'll just see this in the
directly
and that's gotten me in trouble
sometimes
so I'm still working on that from time
to time
okay so advice to new writers and
directors is follow protocol yeah
there's definitely a protocol that you
should be following and and definitely
follow that protocol yeah yeah
what if someone says well I'm a rule
breaker and that's how I've gotten
things done I go outside the lines yeah
there are people like myself who are
sometimes will go outside the lines and
break rules but just know that there's
going to be possibly some consequences
of that and as long as you're ready to
to accept those consequences go have at
it